the national enquirer turns on president
Trump box wagons Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
to run for president even though she's
not eligible and the Boy Scouts verge on
bankruptcy I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
so many things to talk about today we'll
get to all of them we'll analyze all of
the things happening in this beautiful
world before the advent of Christmas but
we begin before that by talking about
the fact you're losing your hair I know
I it's depressing I know you don't want
to think that you look like your father
but here's the reality as we get older
we tend to lose our hair I know my
father has male pattern baldness and
that is why I am a big fan of keeps
losing your hair sucks but there is
something that you can do about it
that's why you should be using keeps the
easiest and most affordable way to keep
the hair that you have they have a
couple of fda-approved products that
cost a lot of money if you do not get
them through keeps but it is much
cheaper if you get them through keeps
for five minutes now in just a buck a
day you're never gonna have to worry
about hair loss again getting started
with keeps is really easy sign up takes
less than five minutes just answer a few
questions snap some photos of your hair
and then a licensed physician reviews
your information online and recommends
the right treatment for you it's shipped
directly to your door every three months
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there some of you probably tried
them before you've probably never gotten
them for this kind of price keeps his
only ten bucks to 35 bucks a month I
know what these medicines cost and it is
not generally 10 bucks to 35 bucks a
month's a lot more keeps makes it a lot
cheaper plus now you can get your first
month for free which is a heck of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair to receive
your first month of treatment for free
go to keeps calm slash pen that is ke
EPS calm slash pen again a free month of
treatment at keeps calm and slash men go
check them out right now keeps hair
today hair tomorrow alrighty so we begin
today with all of the hubbub that has
now broken out amidst the Michael Cohen
sentencing so as you recall from
yesterday's show in the ongoing legal
saga that is the Trump administration
Michael Cohen the president's personal
attorney was sentenced to three years in
jail which was not good for President
Trump who's particularly not good for
President Trump because of the ancillary
details of the actual plea agreement
judge William Pauley the third said that
Michael Cohen had committed a bevy of
crimes with an eye toward deception
Cohen for his part threw himself on the
mercy of the court
he said quote I blame myself for the
conduct which has brought me here today
and it was my own weakness and blind
loyalty to President Trump that led me
to choose a path of darkness over light
so dude has watched a few too many mafia
movies he added time and again I felt it
was my duty to cover up his dirty deeds
rather than to listen to my own inner
voice and my more
compass and then there was this weird
shot of him in an abandoned home in like
Arizona suburbia looking wistfully into
the camera back at the days when he was
a good fella more damaging than Cohen's
open court Mia Copa was that the
prosecution made an announcement they
announced they'd reached a
non-prosecution agreement with America
Media Inc which is the parent company of
the National Enquirer now you'll recall
that President Trump had an arrangement
with the National Enquirer in which
essentially he was going to provide the
National Enquirer for cash the National
Enquirer was going to take that cash and
then pay off women to say silence what
the National Enquirer would do is they
would go to Trump paramours they would
buy their life rights and then they
would sell those life rights to
President Trump for a certain amount of
money that was basically the way that
this chain of custody worked when it
came to these sorts of stories Trump
would use the National Enquirer
basically a funnel hush money well now
ami has decided that they are going to
work with the Southern District of New
York and turn on President Trump so am I
as I say I would purchase the stories of
trumps lovers and then bury them at
Trump's behest Cohen would then attempt
to reimburse ami so the allegations go
so according to prosecutors am i
American American media Inc which again
is the parent company of the National
Enquirer admitted it made a hundred they
made a one hundred and fifty thousand
dollar payment in concert with a
candidate's presidential campaign and in
order to ensure that former Trump
paramour Karen McDougal did not
publicize damaging allegations about the
candidate before the 2016 presidential
election am i further admitted that it's
principal purpose in making the payment
was to suppress the woman's story so as
to prevent it from influencing the
election now the reason that this is
very damaging is because the way that
campaign finance law works is that if
you violate campaign finance law it must
be on the basis of you having made an
unreported expenditure intended to
influence the campaign and presidents
from defense as I've been saying for a
long time on this particular score would
be yes I paid off women but I didn't do
it influence that campaign I've been
paying off women for years right which
is absolutely credible in the case of
President Trump so wouldn't be a
campaign related expense any more than
you buying a suit to wear on a campaign
is a campaign related expense you would
have bought the suit anyway it's just
that now you're doing it in the middle
of a campaign it's the reason that you
can't just blame everything on campaign
expenditures you actually have to kind
of file
you have to filter out all of these
stuff that is campaign expenditure from
non campaign expenditure so there
basically been two lines of Defense that
President Trump has been urged to use by
his defenders on this particular score
number one
this wasn't a campaign expenditure by
Michael Cohen or by America Media Inc if
he was involved in that particular path
and number two that even if it was a
payoff he would lied on the advice of
his attorney Michael Cohen and Michael
Cohen's the attorney so it's his job to
determine whether or not the law was
being complied with well the first prong
of that attack is sort of falling apart
the idea that this was not campaign
related if ami is going to now testify
if executives today am I including
people like David pecker who's a good
friend of president Trump's are now
going to testify that Trump explicitly
said to them hey guys I've got an
election coming up and I really need you
to buy up other stories of the women I
screwed here as he go like if he said
that then it's gonna be hard from the
claim that it was not campaign related
that it wasn't intended to influence the
campaign while Cohn didn't actually use
ami to silence his silence stormy
Daniels representatives of am I were the
first to notify Michael Cohen of stormy
Daniels is intent to go public according
to prosecutors again all of this
undercuts the case that President Trump
could make that he paid hush money on a
regular basis outside of election
circumstances so Trump is now going to
have to claim in defense that both ami
and Cohen are lying about such
expenditures representing a legal
campaign allocations that he would have
done it anyway and that they have caved
to the pressure of rogue prosecutors
alternatively he's gonna have to blame
Cohen for the violations as I say now
none of this bodes particularly well for
President Trump
President Trump cannot be prosecuted as
president according to Justice
Department guidelines but that doesn't
mean that a looming indictment wouldn't
change the math for 2020 I think one of
the great mysteries in the presidential
politics is that if you are in Pietra
downs sort of to your benefit but if
you're impeached that it doesn't hurt
you politically and the case that people
tend to make here is with regard to Bill
Clinton's because when Bill Clinton was
impeached by the house but he wasn't
convicted by the Senate his approval
rating rose people saw it as a
witch-hunt and Bill Clinton was sort of
exonerated by his own party and by the
American people the problem is Bill
Clinton was a lame duck and the same
thing is true of Richard Nixon when
Richard Nixon resigned in the middle of
Watergate he was in fact a lame duck if
Richard Nixon had been in his first term
during Watergate
does anyone think he would have won a
second term after that how about Bill
Clinton
had been hit with a perjury and
obstruction charge and been impeached in
say 1994 as opposed to 1999 does anybody
actually think that he would have won
re-election in 1996 the evidence that it
hurts people that hurts the party of
that is impeached more than it doesn't
is that in 2000 if you recall Al Gore
should have won that election running
away he had a very solid economy he had
a record of Clinton's deficit reduction
he had a solid campaign apparatus behind
him and because of Bill Clinton's
turmoil he forcibly disassociated
himself from Clinton he would not
campaign with Clinton and George HW Bush
ran a campaign based on I'm gonna bring
honor and decency back to the Oval
Office that was actually the main thrust
of his campaign in 2000 and it cost I'll
go to the White House so the idea that
it doesn't have negative ramifications
for you as a candidate or your party as
a candidate if you are impeached I am
not sure that that is the case certainly
it's riskier than not impeaching Trump
but I'm not sure that if the Democrats
were to impeach Trump in the house on
the basis of for example obstruction of
justice or perjury that it would
necessarily redound to president Trump's
benefit and again those would be the
actual crimes that we're talking about
with with regard to President Trump so
there are three crimes that are on the
table with regard to President Trump to
do the quick legal analysis here crime
number one would be active promotion of
a campaign finance violations that would
be he went to Michael Cohen he said
listen dude I know this violates
campaign law but take this money and go
pay out the ladies and don't report it
do it and Cohn was like well sir that
could violate campaign financing and for
me I don't care do it anyway like that
would be campaign finance violation
that's case number one case number two
is that Trump didn't necessarily say
that but when Michael Cohen went back to
trumpet he said listen the FBI is
looking into me and they want me to
testify that you had nothing to do that
you had everything to do with the
payment and that you knew all about the
payments and that you were deeply
involved in the payments that they were
campaign related and then Trump said I
want you to go and I want you to lie I
won't you just tell yeah nothing I want
you to lie if Trump did that there'd be
obstruction of justice that's what Bill
Clinton did in 1998 with regard to the
Paula Jones case right the reason that
Bill Clinton ended up being impeached
was for obstruction of justice and
perjury the perjury charges came when he
was asked specifically about his
relationship
monica lewinsky and he said that he did
not have a sexual relationship with
monica lewinsky he used the present
tense and that's where you got that
famous quote it depends on the meaning
of what is is meaning that present tense
he didn't have a sexual relationship
with Monica Lewinsky but he had in the
past he was charged with perjury and
impeached in the house on that basis and
then obstruction of justice was he had
informed people around him that he
wanted them to lie particularly his
secretary he wanted her to lie about his
relationship with Monica Lewinsky that
was considered obstruction of justice so
remember the perjury and obstruction of
justice charges with regard to Bill
Clinton had nothing to do with an
underlying crime it wasn't an actual
crime for Bill Clinton to sleep with
Monica Lewinsky there's a crime for him
to lie to the congressional
investigators about it and was a crime
for him to tell other people to lie to
congressional investigators with the FBI
about it you could have a very similar
circumstance here where Michael Cohen
didn't actually even commit a campaign
finance violation and Trump didn't
commit a campaign finance violation but
Trump told Michael Collins to lie to
people in positions of legal authority
about this and then you get obstruction
of justice and perhaps perjury depending
on what Trump actually said in his
deposition by the FBI remember he has
turned in written answers to Robert
Muller presumably the the perjury charge
from there would arise in the context of
from saying for example that he didn't
know about the Trump Tower meeting and
then you have a bunch of people who say
no he absolutely knew about the Trump
Tower meeting and so you have a case of
perjury so again from tower meeting not
illegal the the affairs with stormy
Daniels and Karen McDougal and the
payoffs to them not illegal but crimes
can arise from non illegal activity if
you end up telling people to fib to
legal authorities like the FBI or the
DOJ and and that is where the peril
lives for president Trump now a
competent lawyer will say at this point
the President Trump should shut his face
right I mean this is as I've said many
times on the program the first thing to
know about when the FBI comes calling is
get a lawyer and shut up and this is
true for anyone okay this is true for
anyone now there are people who are
saying that you know you won't you want
to urge people to talk to the FBI and
the DOJ that's true as a general matter
I would like for people to talk with the
FBI and the DOJ and the police and law
enforcement authorities that we can
track down crime and solve those crimes
I'm saying that if I were the defense
counsel for somebody if he were my job
to defend you any lawyer worth his salt
will tell you first rule of order get a
lawyer in the room and then don't answer
questions unless your lawyer says that
it's okay to answer the questions
certainly don't go on Twitter and start
tweeting about your legal strategy and
yet as we shall see being president
Trump's lawyer is a barrel of laughs so
here we'll talk about what President
Trump had to tweet about he started
tweeting out his legal strategy this
morning which is always honestly if
you're if you're his lawyer you just
want to stick your head in an oven I
mean it's just it's there there are
three really bad jobs in Washington
there many bad jobs in Washington DC
among these bad jobs being the
president's personal attorney being the
press secretary for the White House and
being the chief of staff which is why
they're now going to I think maybe they
should just conflate all of these into
one the president's personal attorney
should become the press secretary and
the chief of staff we can kill three
birds with one stone
or as PETA would have it we can feed
three birds with one scone we'll get to
all of that in just a second but first
let's talk about your ancestry are you
more Native American than Elizabeth
Warren this is the real question of the
day so Lizabeth Warren may have blown up
her presidential campaign because she
decided to release a genetic ancestry
test showing that she may have been one
1024 Native American I decided that I
would take a genetic test from 23andme
because I wanted to find out more about
my ancestry as it turns out truth in
advertising I was 100% Ashkenazi Jewish
I mean that is some pure blood right
there
you know people worry about whether
they're of mixed heritage I mean this is
like Lithuanian Jews marrying each other
for a thousand years and this results in
this check that out right yeah well
23andme confirmed all that and they give
me information about my muscle
composition turns out I am just deeply
athletic my sleep movement do I move a
lot when I sleep the answer of course is
yes the it gives you information about
whether you have a taste aversion to
cilantro an ability to match musical
pitch misophonia which is everyday
noises like sounds of chewing can cause
a reaction of rage or panic do you have
a predilection to that they can actually
test this mosquito bite frequency like
my wife is constantly getting bit by
mosquitoes it turns out there's a
genetic component to that 23andme can
give you all this cool information the
health and ancestry service includes 90
personalized genetic reports that offer
DNA insights on what makes you unique
now through December 25th to get 30% off
any 23andme can it really is a lot of
fun it's enjoyable to go through these
results and you know more about yourself
than you did before order your DNA kit
at 23andme comm slash Shapiro that's the
number two three-and me.com slash
Shapiro again that's 23andme comm slash
Shapiro other folks in the office have
taken the genetic ancestry testing turns
out that I am related to our makeup
artist chess she's point four percent
Jewish so congratulations to Jess on her
upgrade to the nation but it's really
it's really fun stuff and and again find
out whether you're more Native American
than Elizabeth Warren which is really
the only thing anybody cares about at
this point because everyone except for
me is more Native American than
Elizabeth Warren go check it out right
now
23andme comm slash Carol get 30% off any
23andme kit when you use that promo code
Shapiro 23andme comm slash apparel ok so
president Trump the first rule of law
uring is shut your head
president Trump does not abide by that
rule so President Trump decided this
morning to tweet out his entire legal
strategy because when you have 50
million Twitter followers why not lay
out your entire legal strategy in the
middle of an FBI investigation how could
this go wrong so president Trump decides
to tweet out any tweets I had never
directed Michael Cohen to break the law
he was a lawyer he's supposed to know
the law it is called advice of counsel
and a lawyer has great liability if a
mistake is made that is why they get
paid despite that many campaign finance
lawyers have strongly stated I did
nothing wrong with respect to campaign
finance laws if they even apply because
this was not campaign finance Kern was
guilty and many charges unrelated to me
but he pled to to criminal charges
campaign charges which were not criminal
and of which he probably was not guilty
even on a civil basis those charges were
just agreed to by him in order to
embarrass the president and get a much
reduced prison sentence which he did
including the fact that his family was
temporarily let off the hook as a lawyer
michael has great liability to me okay
so I will admit that the best tweet
Trump has ever sent was specifically
about Michael Cohen he sent a tweet
several months ago in which he said if
you ever need a lawyer do not look at
Michael Cohen well you know he thought
of that before he did
what he is saying here is exactly the
legal strategy that I've drawn up for
him now the problem with him saying this
sort of thing out loud is it shows sort
of a motive for him to to say it meaning
that he's now contradicted himself on
Twitter itself remember he says he
didn't pay off stormy Daniels that he
never had an affair with storming
Daniels on Twitter it turns out that all
of that is false we all knew it was
false at the time but he's he's
basically making the case that Michael
Cohen was supposed to protect him that's
what a lawyer is supposed to do and that
is the defense that he's gonna have to
rely on in the end is that Michael Cohen
should have known all this stuff and
Michael Cohen blew it anyway whether
that holds or not is is questionable but
it does set up a really difficult 20/20
run for the president for a couple of
reasons which I'll explain in just a
second so the president looking forward
to 2021 a couple of things can happen
either Democrats can impeach the
president on the basis of obstruction of
justice and perjury or the president is
not impeached and we just jabber about
this and investigated for the next two
years and we run into 20/20 under the
womb incredible for President Trump and
so it becomes President Trump trying to
escape jail by running for president
because when you're president you have
immunity from being imprisoned by law
enforcement authorities
unless you're impeached and you're out
of office if the if the president is
able to survive impeachment which I
think he will up until 2020 but the
indictment is still on the table then
basically he's going to be running under
the threat of indictments that if you
let him not be president anymore he will
immediately be sent to prison by the
Southern District of New York that
obviously is a different color for an
election that we have ever seen in
American politics before now it does set
up a conundrum for the Democrats which
is is it better to impeach him now and
move toward impeachment now or is it
better to run under the circumstance I
think everyone sort of agrees it's
better that if you can you run under
those circumstances in 2020 you just
keep jabbering and yelling about how
Trump is an obstructive justice and a
liar and a perjurer and then you run
against him it's better to do that than
to impeach him and then the Senate
acquits him and then the story's
basically over Alan Dershowitz who's
been a big defender of the president and
a lot of this and of course is a defense
lawyer was a defense lawyer for a living
he says that it's ridiculous to talk
about impeaching Trump over this sort of
stuff anyway I don't think he's going to
come up with an impeachable offense
remember the Constitution requires
treason
every other high crimes and misdemeanors
the most they've come up with is a very
very questionable campaign contribution
issue which failed when they tried it
against Edward some years ago so I don't
think we're an impeachment land okay so
I think that he is probably right but
only because of Bill Clinton so what's
really amazing is watching all the
people who thought that Bill Clinton
should not be impeached
turn around and now say that Donald
Trump should be impeached on the same
basis now here is my general here's
here's my general take on whether Trump
should be impeached if all of this stuff
happens to be true
if we were talking about we're now
living in 1994 1993 1996 so we're trying
to uphold a certain standard of what the
presidency is then any president who is
credibly accused of obstruction of
justice or perjury or would be indicted
on that basis should be impeached which
is why I was in favor of the Bill
Clinton impeachment but let's be real
about this the math changed and it was
change by Brooklyn it's not just that
the Democrats held Bill Clinton to no
standard it's that the realities on the
ground changed themselves is that the
realities on the ground change Donald
Trump is not president if Bill Clinton
is not impeached right if Bill Cliff
Bill Clinton is impeached rather Bill
Clinton been impeached in 1999 Donald
Trump is not president today Bill
Clinton lowered the standard from what a
president could be so much that by the
time we got to Donald Trump in 2016
everybody just went listen we know that
a president doesn't have to have high
moral fiber
we had Bill Clinton we know that a
president can have corruption issues we
had Bill Clinton you guys are running
Hillary Clinton in this election and
then lecturing us about higher character
in the election you can't do this this
is not a real thing and that's basically
correct I'm not gonna go back to the old
standard I don't think it's it's even
credible to go back to the old standard
of what the presidency was before Bill
Clinton because let's be let's be frank
about this
there hasn't been no morals change of
mind on the part of Democrats now what
you're gonna see over the next two years
here's the prediction now over the next
two years what you're going to begin to
see is a bunch of Democrats coming out
and saying you know what thinking about
it now we should have gotten rid of Bill
Clinton we should have impeached him but
they started to do this last year in the
middle of the me2 movement well you know
we really should have taken wanita
broderick more seriously right but you
didn't and I don't trust that you would
if it happened again today if we were
talking about a Democrat in office
having committed the same
sort of quasi crimes are accused crimes
as president Trump Democrats would not
be talking about impeaching they would
be talking about defending that is the
world in which we live the standard that
was used in 1999 for Bill Clinton
retaining office by the way he retained
office under a Republican Senate a
Republican Senate voted not to convict
him in the impeachment case the standard
that was used was could Bill Clinton
credibly continue to carry out his job
or had he lost the faith of the American
people because of the charges upon him
and the answer that the Senate gave was
no he could still credibly perform his
job so we can't throw him out of office
for high crimes and misdemeanors even
though he was impeached in the house
that standard still applies to President
Trump
Republicans would I think there's a case
that people are making that Republicans
would be smart to convict President
Trump in the Senate I think that's
ridiculous politically speaking too much
of the base is invested in president
from personally the idea of throwing him
out of office on what look like
ticky-tack fouls that are certainly no
worse than what Bill Clinton did in 1999
I think you want to split the base
that's a good way to do it but does all
this bode well for 2020 I can't say that
that it does and I would prefer that it
had not been a thing but unfortunately
it is a thing and so we all have to move
forward with it now in other news I want
to talk about in just a second
presidents from facing down Democrats
over border funding we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
how you invest so my Secretary has now
been my assistant has now been using the
Robin Hood app for her investments and
she loves it I mean she told me this
morning that what should the Robin Hood
app is specifically tailored to you it
asks you questions like what are your
investment goals are you doing it to
save are you doing it to risk are you
are you looking for certain types of
stocks it asks you your income so that
it can tailor a strategy specifically
for you and that's what Robin Hood does
Robin Hood is investing app that lets
you buy and sell stocks ETFs options and
Kryptos all commission-free they strive
to make Financial Services work for
everyone not just wealthy folks it's a
non intimidating way for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time
with true confidence it's simple and
intuitive it's got a clear design with
data presented in an easy to digest way
other brokerages charge up to 10 bucks
for every trade Robin Hood doesn't
charge commission feeds you can trade
the stocks and keep all of your profits
they've got ease of use their design is
really clear and obvious the web
platform lets you view stock collections
that are curated just for you
analyst ratings buy a hold it and sell
it asks you upfront how much you know
the market or whether you know the
market at all so that it can teach you
how the market works Robin Hood right
now is giving my listeners a free stock
like Apple order sprint to help build
your portfolio
sign up at Shapiro Robin Hood calm
that's Shapiro Robin Hood calm and again
when you use that promo code Shapiro
Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm you get a
free stock like Apple Ford or Sprint's
helped build that portfolio it's a great
way to learn to invest folks around the
office of been using it they say that
it's really fantastic go check it out
right now
it's Shapiro dot Robin Hood calm okay
meanwhile the presidents of the United
States has been caught up in this talk
of a government shutdown with the
Democrats and the Democrats are saying
we are not going to fund this border
wall no matter what this is a winning
campaign issue for the president if
Democrats refused to give the president
his funding for a border wall and the
president says listen I'm not signing
anything without that funding in it
because they will not provide you the
necessary security the necessary the
necessary prevention against dangerous
people getting into the country that's a
winning issue for the president and the
Democrats are proving themselves
intransigent it's amazing to me that the
Democrats don't just give him the
funding I understand that they want the
political win of being able to say that
they prevented Trump from getting the
funding but it doesn't seem worth it to
me so what wouldn't they look stronger
on security if they just you know what
the president is right we need to be
stronger on border security so we're
giving him the funding for border
security and we're doing so in order to
make the country safer is that a huge
win for Trump that's gonna win him vast
swaths of voters across the country I
don't think so especially if Democrats
tried to show themselves as partners in
all of this as opposed to obstruct errs
and all this instead they decided that
this is a hill they're willing to die on
President Trump should make them stand
on that hill over and over and over
again
so Bernie Sanders is one of the folks
who's pushing this Bernie Sanders is so
wild and the Democrats are so wild that
Bernie Sanders says he would not even
trade citizenship for the dreamers
meaning people who arrived here below
the age of majority as children or young
teenagers he wouldn't trade citizenship
for them for a wall so he would leave
he'd rather leave legitimately hundreds
of thousands of millions of illegal
immigrants who could get citizenship in
a deal off the table just so that
President Trump can't build a border
wall it's an insane position but it is
the mainstream Democratic position
here's Bernie Sanders of a month whose
fading in the polls but not fading in
our hearts
bunny founders go what's wrong with the
move of saying with the Democrats say
quietly which is we're in favor of
border security we're funding the stuff
that they're doing on the border right
now
give them the wall and get back what you
want for the dreamers my understanding
is he does not have the votes in the
house and I think there are a lot of
folks here in the Senate Republicans who
are also not supportive of building the
wall alrightso wall for dreamers not on
the table for bernie sanders and then
chuck schumer comes out and he says
president Trump is gonna hold the
government hostage for a campaign pledge
well first of all that is what every
president has done Barack Obama did it
also when the Republican Congress
refused to pass a budget that included
funding for Obamacare Obama shut down
the government right Obama's head okay
well I won't sign it I'm not gonna sign
it that well Chuck Schumer says how dare
President Trump do the same thing
President Obama did on his priorities
that's crazy talk president Trump made
clear he'll hold parts of the government
hostage for a petty campaign pledge to
fire up his base that's all it is
okay that is absurd and it is not true
you know the president pledge is a
matter of border security and he is not
wrong to push it but the Democrats are
very radical on this issue and that's a
winning issue for the President of the
United States how radical are Democrats
on this issue here's an editorial from
the Boston Globe about this hey they're
very very upset because the president
over the last week has expanded his plan
to dramatically expand the so-called
public charge rule
okay the public charge rule says that
the administration is not going to allow
people to come into the country who
might become a public charge in other
words you don't get to come in the
country if you're gonna come here and be
on public benefits so according to the
Boston Globe the rule is meant to
prevent people who might become a public
charge from entering or establishing
legal residency in the United States
historically the test was narrow
designed to identify those would rely on
the government as their main source of
support the test considered only cash
based aid which only 3% of non-citizens
use Trump wants to expand factors
considered to include food stamps and
housing assistant programs like section
8 Medicaid among others additionally
establishes new factors that would count
against non-citizens earning an income
of less than 125 percent of the federal
poverty level lacking English
proficiency having a poor credit score
or being older than 61 or younger than
18 these new rules would apply to
foreign-born individuals seeking a green
card and to some abroad
requesting visas why is it any of that
unreasonable I think if you ask the
American people do you want people
immigrating to the country who depress
wages because they earn low wages abroad
we have low levels of education who are
more likely to depend on food stamps in
section 8 housing most Americans would
say no we don't want those people coming
into the country just as a general rule
because if they're going to take
advantage of our public benefits
programs then how are they of net
benefit to American society
now I'm libertarian on immigration in a
non social welfare based system when my
great-grandparents came to the United
States great great grandparents came to
the United States in 1907 1908 there
were none of these social welfare
programs in place if there are no social
welfare programs in place and you just
want to come here and work you just want
to come here and be free then more power
to you come on in but if you're coming
here and you're likely to rely on public
benefits how exactly do you hope that we
are going to be able to support those
public benefits on the back of such
immigration policies but Democrats on
the Left are so radical on this that
they say that if you don't agree that we
should bring in people to be on our
welfare systems then this means that
you're some sort of racist or xenophobe
so it really is an amazing amazing
statement by folks on the left
the Boston Globe concludes in the past
the government has encouraged low-income
people to enroll in public assistance
programs like food stamps and Medicaid
so be especially unfair to make those
choices count against immigrants now why
why I mean just because the government
had bad policy in the past we have to
maintain that bad policy now it was set
with so much harm what could possibly be
in the intent of this policy change
Homeland Security said in a statement
that the policy would quote promote
immigrant self-sufficiency and protect
finite resources by ensuring that they
are not likely to become burdens on
American taxpayers this is called
rationality but the rule says the Boston
Globe would do exactly the opposite it
would low-income immigrant
families or doing everything by the book
and trigger aftershocks that would hurt
all Americans no it's no it would it
would remove people from the public
rolls is is what it would do but this is
how extreme the Democrats are they say
not only should we not build the wall we
should encourage people to come here and
then we should tell them to get on
public benefits that's a radical
position most Americans don't agree with
this and so when folks on the Left say
that Trump's border policy is all about
xenophobia and racism it just doesn't
ring true
in any real sense that's not gonna stop
them from saying it though CNN's Angela
rice as that Trump's wall is all about
xenophobia and racism because for the
left everything Republicans do is about
xenophobia and racism Donald Trump is
fixated on the southern border as he was
the day that he announced this campaign
it is not about securing the borders it
is about xenophobic racist bigoted
beliefs that he told ok it is it is not
about that it is about the fact that
most Americans agree that we ought to
secure our borders now President Trump
is doing something very silly this
morning he made a promise during his
campaign that he was going to build the
wall and make the Mexicans pay for it
wasn't make Mexican government pay for
it right that was knows his idea and it
was always silly I said it during the
campaign Mexican government was not
gonna pay for the building of a border
wall that was a ridiculous contention
but Trump is now trying to claim that he
had somehow successfully done this how
because he cut a new trade deal with
Mexico so he tweeted out this morning
about NAFTA he tweeted I often stated
one way or the other Mexico is going to
pay for the WHA this has never changed
our new deal with Mexico and Canada the
u.s. MCA is so much better than the old
very costly an anti us a NAFTA there
that just by the money we save Mexico is
paying for the WHA no that is not true
but that is not true okay so first of
all it is incumbent upon us to say that
the u.s. MCA the new trade deal is 95
percent the same as NAFTA the idea that
Mexico is going to be paying for the
wall through a better trade deal is just
silliness okay that's that that is not
accurate if the trade deal is better
that means both sides benefit so I don't
understand how that pays for it the
border wall if this is Trump's idea of
fulfilling a promise that's silly but
again it was a silly promise to begin
with and no one was gonna hold them to
it anyway the only question is whether
he actually builds the wall and pleases
all of his fans who wanted him to build
the wall it seems like unfortunately
President Trump is making noises in
which he's gonna claim that he's already
built the wall even though he has not
the Department of Homeland Security put
out a memo today saying that the wall
has never been built higher than it is
now in other words we didn't build new
wall but we extended upward the wall
that we already had that the fencing
that we already had yeah if you want to
buy that you can buy it but that is not
a fulfillment of his campaign promise
okay in just a second I want to get to
media bias because we have a couple of
maize
stories of media bias over the over the
last couple of days and then we also
have to talk about the increased
radicalism inside the Democratic Party
and the Boy Scouts on the verge of
bankruptcy but first let's talk a little
bit of about another podcast that you
ought to give a listen to this podcast
is called kingpins if you like podcasts
about greed and corruption there's a new
podcast from podcast network it's called
kingpins kingpins takes a deep dive into
the minds and stories of the men and
women who call the shots of the criminal
underworld I love stuff like this and
there's a great show on Netflix called
narcos about Pablo Escobar and the drug
cartels well they're episodes coming up
on kingpins all about Pablo Escobar and
Thelma Wright and Al Capone about people
who control the landscape around them
and use force and cruelty to to control
it use extortion and violence and even
murder protects their empires you know
the the misuses of human power one of my
chief sources of fascination in life and
kingpins really takes it on on a
narrative level it's really fascinating
stuff listen today by searching and
subscribing to kingpins wherever you
listen to podcasts that is ki ki ng P I
and s kingpins or visit podcast.com
slash kingpins to start listening now
that's PARC a st.com slash King him
kingpins to start listening now if
you're into crime podcasts if you are
into exciting narrative podcast you
won't want to miss podcasts kingpins go
find it at any place you listen to
podcast again the podcast is called
kingpins go check it out right now okay
for more on media bias and and all the
rest we have pretty good things I like
and things I hate coming up today you're
gonna want to go over to Daley wire.com
and subscribe we have so many great
things coming for you in the new year
when you become a subscriber you get not
only the rest of all the shows live and
all the rest of it and ability to join
the mailbag and ability to ask questions
during the during the conversations you
also are going to be able to ask me
questions live on air like every day
when you're a subscriber because we're
doing two more hours of the show every
day that's how hard I'm slaving my
fingers to the bone for you people so
all you have to do is go become a
subscriber and then you get access to
that stuff and it's a we're doing a live
radio show and we'll be simulcasting
that and I'll be answering your
questions during the commercial breaks
and everything it's gonna be a blast
go check it out over at daily wire comm
for $9.99 a month and for $99 here you
get this the very greatest in beverage
aha you see it cast your eyes upon it
and despair the leftist tears hot or
cold tumblr you will enjoy it you will
live it you will love it you'll get all
of those great things also go check us
out at YouTube or iTunes that means that
when you subscribe you also get our
Sunday specials we have a bunch of
awesome Sunday specials coming up in the
very near future this Sunday is Bishop
Robert Barron so we will be discussing
theology and philosophy and all sorts of
the deep topics that you want to hear
about go check that out right now please
leave us a review when you do subscribe
over to iTunes it always helps us with
the rankings we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
okay so the media obviously are wildly
biased against Republicans and you can
see it in terms not only of the
immigration debate where you have
everybody ripping on president Trump's
eminently practical policies with regard
to illegal immigration but in virtually
every aspect of the media it is amazing
how much the left will go out of its way
in the media to cover for its own to
cover for members of the media who are
on the left and to cover for politicians
on the left and this is how you end up
with stories like this one from the LA
Times so it turns out that the CEO of
the LA Times was was talking openly
about a Jewish cabal that ran Los
Angeles hey here's the article from NPR
several months after taking control of
the troubled Tribune publishing company
in 2016 Chicago investor Michael Farrow
convened a session of corporate leaders
from within his own news empire
including chief news executives from
such storied papers as the LA Times the
Chicago Tribune and the Baltimore Sun
the group of about 20 people trooped
from Chicago's iconic Tribune Tower on
Michigan Avenue to an upscale restaurant
nearby in a private room participants
dined on seafood and steak while farro
then the company's chairman held forth
on his plans his own net worth net worth
was newly in the nine figures associates
and peers say Farah hold held ambitions
they're wide ranging even audacious
given the newspaper industry's stiff
headwinds at the dinner as in other
moments Farrell railed against those he
felt were impeding him including
perceived rivals and competitors among
them Eli Broad who's a Southern
California billionaire and civic leader
Farrell called him part of a Jewish
cabal that ran Los Angeles a spokesman
for Farrell denied the incident occurred
and called the claim reckless
allegations nothing really spells out
how much you should trust the media then
that a bunch of members of the media
we're in a room with a high-powered guy
who owns a bunch of newspapers and
failed to report for several years that
the man was talking about a Jewish cabal
running Los Angeles it's amazing how the
left is willing to accept anti-semitism
when it comes from its own ranks Tribune
publishing made the first in a series of
secret payments to total more than 2.5
million dollars to avert a threatened
lawsuit filed by a fired newspaper
executive according to three people with
knowledge of the deal that had the
effect of keeping Pharaoh's anti-semitic
slur out of the public spotlight so in
other words intrepid journalists sitting
at the stinner hearing the CEO of the LA
rail against the Jewish cabal in Los
Angeles they several choices choice
number one
tell him to pipe down maybe get fired
and then go public choice number two in
a sign an investigative reporter
they'll uncover the stuff be a fireman
the way you say you're a fireman choice
number three try to sue the guy for 2.5
million dollars and then keep the things
Island and our intrepid firemen chose
number three solid stuff intrepid
firemen also not a shock from the folks
at the LA Times who have legitimately
for years on end hidden a tape now it's
been hidden for a full decade a tape of
then-senator Barack Obama attending a
party at which Rashid Khalidi an actual
terrorist spokesperson spoke up in his
favor and then Obama spoke about him
that tape should have come out during
2008 the LA Times hit it and they
refused the offer of payment of I think
was a hundred thousand dollars from
Andrew Breitbart to released the tape
how long do you think it would have
taken for that tape to lease to release
if it had been to leak if it had been a
Republican making such comments media
bias is pretty extraordinary and media
bias is so extraordinary you can get
away with pretty much anything so long
as you're are still in the leftist
wheelhouse case in point Mika Brzezinski
so yesterday on MSNBC Mika Brzezinski
was talking about Mike Pompeo who is the
Secretary of State and she's very angry
that secretary Pompeo is what she
believes is being weak with dictators
around the world and she proceeded to
use a phrase that if any republican used
it that Republican would immediately
lose his job she still maintains her job
because that's how this works joy Reid
can say whatever homophobic thing she
wants and maintain on MSNBC and Mika
Brzezinski can say whatever homophobic
thing she wants and maintain her job on
MSNBC here's what she said yesterday so
Joe I just I have to ask because I don't
think there I can't think of anyone here
who could put it more clearly than you
know I understand that Donald Trump
doesn't care
Heilmann makes a good point he doesn't
care but why doesn't Mike Pompeo care
right now but are the pathetic
deflections that we just heard when he
appeared on Fox and Friends is that a
patriot speaking or a wannabe dictators
butt boy dead serious I'm asking are
these the words of a patriot he's debase
himself he once again is under looks
like flies right over the radar under
the radar for these folks like that
everybody who's sitting there
saying this nobody thought oh it's bad
to say but boy which is a homophobic
homophobic term mika brzezinski
cater came out later and apologized to
totally agree with you super bad choice
of words
I should have said water boil it for
football teams or something like that I
apologized to dick Durbin too so sorry
well I guess that it just goes away now
it's a good thing that you don't want I
guess you can't host the Oscars anymore
though so that's that's exciting news
cuz I'm not sure anybody would watch the
Oscars hosted by Mika Brzezinski
so again she gets away with it anybody
does that on Fox News they're
immediately suspended maybe fired
because that's the way that the media
protect their own well because the media
are so far to the left that is
increasing the radicalism inside the
Democratic Party and this does have
consequences so how exactly how radical
is the Democratic Party becoming what
has happened inside the Democratic Party
is that Bernie Sanders has become the
mainstream it's one of the reasons why
Bernie Sanders is not going to run
successfully in 2020 he made the mistake
of being too successful in 2016 the
Democratic Party decided to basically
cannibalize Bernie Sanders his campaign
and then ingest it and then poop out a
bunch of candidates who mirror Bernie
Sanders's priorities so here is Bernie
Sanders yesterday talking about greedy
billionaires controlling the USA the
only real question about this is is
there any Democrat who's gonna run in
2020 who disagrees with this I really
doubt it we live in a nation owned and
controlled by a small number of multi
billionaires whose greed incredible
greed insatiable greed is having an
unbelievably negative impact on the
fabric of our entire ok this is the
exact same language with everyone the
Democratic Party now uses particularly
folks like Alexandra Ocasio Cortez who I
bring up because again I know every time
we talk about Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
were accused of being obsessed with her
except that there are there articles in
mainstream media today calling for her
to run for president she's not even
eligible for the presidency if we 35 to
be President of the United States
Alexander Ocasio Cortez who does not
know things is 29 years old and she's
being touted as the new hot thing in
Congress because she's good at social
media which she eminently is Matthew
Iglesias who is a dummy in Matthew
Iglesias the Ralph Wiggum of political
commentary over at voxcom he has an
article today called it's ridiculous
that it's unconstitutional for Alexandra
Ocasio Cortez to run for president
he says Alexandra Ocasio Cortez is the
biggest star in the Democratic Party and
she's been ever since she unseated
representative Joe Crowley in a surprise
primary upset in May that her win didn't
in the final analysis launched a wave of
leftist primary victories only goes to
show what a phenomenon she personally is
I mean I don't wish to review the
history here for all that long but
representative Joe Crowley was a
representative from a majority-minority
district and she won 17,000 votes in the
primary okay so like five people showed
up and of those five people three three
voted for Alexandra Ocasio Cortez this
makes her the rising star in any case
Matthew Iglesias says it is very bad
that we prevent people who are not who
who are who are not 35 from running for
president he makes the case that she
should run for president and then she
should dare the Supreme Court to make
her ineligible he says one good sign
that AOC should run for president is
that she has a nickname
AOC it's so does Dwayne the rock Johnson
so to share certainly what you have a
nickname and now you should run for
president El Chapo has a nickname should
he run for president I mean maybe we
should change the constitution so you
don't need American citizens to run for
president and they can be in jail maybe
Matthew Iglesias man that guy was
dropped on his head as a baby many times
and you fell off the stupid tree and hit
every branch on the way down my house
Democratic staffer told me the other day
that a CEO was a good example of
something I knew exactly who she meant
despite the error because there aren't
any other members of Congress who have
widely recognized nicknames you would
just drop into casual conversation is
having a nickname a sign you would
exercise good judgment in the Oval
Office absolutely not
but it's proof positive she's an
honest-to-goodness political superstar
and it's clear that's what many
Democrats are looking for in 2020 he
says not so long ago Arnold
Schwarzenegger cut a kind of vaguely
trumpet figure in California politics
had he run for president in 2012 he
probably would have lost badly in the
primaries on the grounds of not being
right-wing enough but it's at least
conceivable he would have won and he'd
have been a tough opponent for Barack
Obama to beat for the best possible
reasons his politics are considerably
saner and more humane than the average
Republican but he didn't run we never
got a glimpse of what a run would look
like because immigrants like
20-somethings are constitutionally
barred from serving
hey let's make something very clear the
35 year old age limit on people
running for presidents of the United
States is considerably too low I say
this is somebody who's about to turn 35
in January it's considerably too low
people were running for president at 35
and were allowed to do so because you
were working when you were like 13 and
you were dying when you were 50 35 in in
1789 35 and 1789 is basically the
equivalent of like 55 now so I don't
know by what logic you have the so you
live in your mother's basement you
should run for president like by what
logic are people more mature at 35 now
than they were two hundred years ago is
there any logic by which this is true
there is no logic by which this is true
this is just a bunch of crap but this is
how biased folks in the media are and
this is how insane they are it's it's
really really crazy but that's not the
only article at AOC there's another one
from the Washington Post talking about
how she's so great at rolling her
conservative critics it's so weird when
Trump trolls leftists then it's because
he's evil and bad and main when aoc the
beloved AOC trolls conservatives then
this means she's brilliant and wonderful
and then you wonder how you got Trump
you trolled us into trolling you and so
will troll you under trolling us until
be trolls all around it'll be great
congratulations on ruining American
politics everyone you've done an
excellent job okay in just a second I
want to talk about the Boy Scouts and
other things let's talk about some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so things that I like it was in
the car the other day and I recalled
that when I was growing up my dad was a
big Dave Grusin fan Dave Grusin is a
jazz musician he's written a bunch of
really good movie scores his best movie
score is the score for on Golden Pond
that year he was nominated for Best
Score Oscar he lost to the score for
Chariots of Fire which is a joke a chair
inspires a wildly overrated score it's
it's a good movie with a mediocre score
on Golden Pond is a good movie with a
great score the movie itself is good as
well
Henry Fonda and and Jane Fonda and
Katharine Hepburn and it's it's all
about aging and family it's a really
good movie it's kind of a forgotten
movie but it is certainly worth watching
so here's a little bit of the preview of
on Golden Pond Universal Pictures
proudly presents a very special motion
picture Katharine Hepburn Henry Fonda
Jane Fonda on Golden Pond listen as
Norman Thayer jr. over on Golden Pond
everything's just waking up Ethel Fair
sound like I'm lisping doesn't it biome
are you have I'm not tied no I put up
there I look sexy
I hear you turned 80 today there what
you heard and that's really old you
should meet my father the movie is
really good I should have won Best
Picture this year Chariots of Fire is
what won Best Picture that year it was a
pretty weak year for movies as the truth
this is this in 1981 the movies that
were nominated for Best Picture that you
were Chariots of Fire Delancey City on
Golden Pond Raiders of the Lost Ark
which is the most memorable of all these
movies and Reds which is the most
overrated of all of these movies but on
Golden Pond is really worth watching
it's a very sweet movie it's it's got a
lot of great acting so much great acting
that it won Best Actor for Henry Fonda
and Best Actress in a leading role for
Katharine Hepburn and was nominated for
Best Actress for Jane Fonda who's really
good in the movie she's not a good
person but a very good actress so go
check out on Golden Pond if you have the
time okay other things that I like so
nikki Haley gave a great interview
yesterday and in this interview she
talked is with NBC News she talked is
sort of for exit interviews she left
being UN ambassador she talked about
president Trump's predictable
unpredictability when it came to foreign
policy and how she was able to utilize
that for good purpose if I needed to
pick up the phone and say this is what
I'm gonna do you know are you good with
this or this we we kind of partnered in
that and so he would like ratchet up the
rhetoric and then I'd go back to the
ambassadors and say you know he's pretty
upset I can't promise you what he's
gonna do or not but I can tell you if we
do these sanctions it will keep him from
going too far so you were playing good
cop bad cop I was trying to get the job
done and I got the job done by being
truthful but also by letting him be
unpredictable and and not showing our
cards okay the fact is that when it
comes to foreign policy president from
some prints ability can in fact be an
asset and as Haley says it has been an
asset in many cases she has a bright
political future ahead of her and
as I say it is sad to me that she's
leaving her post as UN Ambassador but
there's a future for nikki Haley in
politics for sure okay final thing that
I liked so I there there's a great
organization that is run by Gary Sinise
who is a wonderful human being and this
this organization is is entirely
dedicated to the families of soldiers
and remembering the past Gary Sinise
basically took a hundred kids who are
children of people who were ki a or
killed in action and took them to the to
the war memorials in Washington DC and
this was really great a bunch of people
on the ground at the airport where they
were received stood there and cheered
these kids as they got off the plane and
then saying them the national anthem was
really quite moving
[Music]
I mean this stuff is really moving and
he actually sent more than 650 families
who are gold star families to Disney
World
via the Gary Sinise foundation certainly
a charity worthy of your support a
charity worthy of my support is well
worth checking out this was at the
Nashville International Airport where
there was a rendition of the
star-spangled banner where the families
were waiting to board the plane as
service members stood at attention it's
just beautiful stuff and Sinise is known
for being extraordinarily pro-military
and his his service in that respect is
is really extraordinary okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so the Boy
Scouts are now on the verge of
bankruptcy shocker
it turns out that when you abandon the
chief values for what you once stood
people do not want you sign up for your
organization according to The Wall
Street Journal the Boy Scouts of America
is considering filing for bankruptcy
protection as it faces dwindling
membership and escalating legal costs
related to lawsuits over how it handled
allegations of sexual abuse it's not
really that that's bankrupting the Boy
Scouts of America it's that their
membership is wildly down ever since
they decided that they would admit girls
and that they would allow gay Scout
masters and that they would no longer
focus on the judeo-christian heritage of
the organization founded in 1910 the Boy
Scouts say that more than 110 million
people have participated in its
educational programs which promote
outdoor skills character building and
leadership the Boy Scouts have been at
the center of sexual abuse scandals in
the past the organization is facing a
number of lawsuits alleging
inappropriate conduct by employees or
volunteers an incidents dating back as
far as the 1960s but that's not really
what is going on here what's really
going on here is that the Boy Scouts are
being bled dry by people who do not want
to be part of the Boy Scouts now that
they have forcibly caved to the radical
left there's a famous video of me online
talking to a girl about the boy skit
about pronouns gendered pronouns like
boy and girl meaning things meaning
biological boy and girl and why the Boy
Scouts should not allow biological girls
into the Boy Scouts and a woman at one
of my speeches saying well how do you
know that I said because it's in the
name Boy Scouts well then the Boy Scouts
flipped in a grade of her and decided
boy can also mean girl with that kind of
intestinal
a lot of people are not going to join
the Boy Scouts the Boy Scouts currently
have more than 2.3 million youth members
and why exactly are they losing member
as well the Mormons the Church of Jesus
Christ of latter-day saints formerly one
of the groups larger sponsors said that
it's gonna withdraw from the Boy Scout
programs instead they're gonna develop
its own program for young men the Boy
Scouts group drew scrutiny over at slow
pace to become more inclusive but it
wasn't that the boycott that created
problems in the Boy Scouts it was that
they caved to social justice warriors
who insisted that they change their
mainline mission under pressure from
legislators in California who said they
would withdraw 501c3 status from the
group and sponsorship from the group if
the group did not cave to the social
justice warrior demands this is what
happens when when groups that are based
on historic values decide to destroy
those historic values in the name of
convenience nobody wants to stick around
this is true for churches it's true for
synagogues and it's true for the Boy
Scouts as well okay other things that I
hate so in all of the hubbub over Jamal
khashoggi who is the who is the Saudi
Arabian citizen who was murdered by the
Saudi government at the Saudi embassy in
Turkey creating worldwide chaos people
have forgotten a couple of quick things
not about cushaw a rakish Augie himself
controversial figure he had lots of
sympathy toward the Muslim Brotherhood
over the course of his career he was
very much in favor of radical Islamists
taking part in politics and all that but
there's a reason that this information
saw the light of day in the first place
I mean I'm glad that information sees
the light of day but let's not pretend
pretend there wasn't an agenda behind it
the agenda was Turkish president and
dictator Recep Tayyip Argyll on air
Diwan has made himself dictator of
Turkey he's arrested all of his
political opponents he shut down the
press he has prevented political rivals
from being able to gain power he's
jailed political rivals he's tried to
assassinate political rivals himself he
wanted a dissident named Gulen shipped
from the United States back to Turkey so
he could basically do the same thing to
him that the Saudis did to khashoggi
and now era Diwan is saying that he is
going to wipe out the Kurds in eastern
Syria he says that Turkey will launch a
military operation against the Kurds in
northern Syria within days in decision
that could signal a shift in Turkish US
relations and have far-reaching
consequences for Syria's future is
according to the Guardian long
frustrated by US support for Kurdish
militias that Turkey uses terrorists
Erin
has threatened to push deeper into
northeastern Syria since tennant sending
Turkish forces into the Kurdish Enclave
of Afrin in February the president said
in a televised speech in Ankara on
Wednesday the operation was imminent he
said we will begin our operation to free
the east of the Euphrates River from the
separatist organization within a few
days he told the MPS our target is not
American soldiers it is the terror
organizations that are active in the
region
he says the Americans are not being
honest they're still not removing
terrorists from this particular area
meaning Kurds from this particular area
therefore we will do it it it is always
important to recall that whenever
there's a Middle Eastern conflict the
answer usually is there are no good guys
and when it comes to air Dewan he is an
absolute bad human being he's a bad
radical terrorist supporting human being
and the fact that so many people have
fallen for the idea that because air
Dewan says something we have to take it
seriously or that it has no geopolitical
ramifications to take positions that
help dirt on is absurd
Turkey is an extraordinarily powerful
military player in the region they have
a much more powerful military than any
other military in the region with the
possible exception of Israel and the
fact that the Turkish government has
been able to go about its business
without any serious blowback from the
West is an incredible incredible thing
and that were focused more on the Saudis
who are much more helpful to us in
geopolitical terms than the Turks right
now that we are more focused on the
Saudis killing a Saudi citizen on
Turkish in on Saudi territory in Turkey
we're more focused on that than the
Turks going in and wiping out the Kurds
in eastern and northern Syria and
demonstrates that we have very little
geopolitical vision and that we are apt
to fall for it ever is the convenient
narrative that the media wished to tell
us about ongoing geopolitical
conversations another example of that
Ben Rhodes came out recently Ben Rhodes
and national security advisor for
President Obama he came out recently and
he said that the United States should
not be involved in the war on Yemen
where do you think that started it had
started under the Obama administration
who's there the entire time it just
turns out that the Obama administration
had an agenda to push forward the
ambitions of the Iranian government and
Trump doesn't have those ambitions and
because the press loves Obama and hates
Trump they've decided to side with the
ambitions of the Obama administration
even if that means embolden in enemies
of the United States and radical
Islamists across the world
okay well we'll be back here tomorrow to
discuss more on all of this plus
tomorrow's a Friday isn't it so that
means mailbag times we'll be doing that
too we'll see you then I'm Ben Shapiro
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing